The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN TSITSIKLIS: So what we're
going to do is to review what
we have discussed last time.
Then we're going to talk about
the classic application of
Markov chains to analyze
how do you
dimension a phone system.
And finally, there will be
two new things today.
We will see how we can calculate
certain interesting
quantities that have to
do with Markov chains.
So let us start.
We've got our Markov chain and
let's make the assumption that
our chain is kind of nice.
And by nice we mean that
we've got maybe
some transient states.
And then we've got a single
recurrent class
of recurrent states.
So this is a single recurrent
class in the sense that from
any state in that class you can
get to any other state.
So once you're in here you're
going to circulate and keep
visiting all of those states.
Those states appear transient.
The trajectory may move around
here, but eventually one of
these transitions will happen
and you're going to
end up in this lump.
Let's make the assumption that
the single recurrent class is
not periodic.
These are the nicest kind
of Markov chains.
And they're nicest because
they have the following
property, the probability that
you find yourself at some
particular state j at
the time n when that
time is very large.
That probability settles to a
steady state value that we
denote by pi sub j.
And there are two parts
in the statement.
One part is that this
limit exists.
So the probability of state j
settles to something, and
furthermore that probability
is not affected by i.
It doesn't matter where you
started, no matter where you
started, the probability of
state j is going to be the
same in the long run.
Maybe a clearer notation
could be of this form.
The probability of being at
state j given the initial
state being i is equal to
pi(j) in the limit.
Now, if I don't tell you where
you started and you look at
the unconditional probability
of being at state i, you can
average over the initial
states, use the total
expectation theorem and you're
going to get the same answer
pi(j) in the limit.
So this tells you that to the
conditional probability given
the initial state in the limit
is the same as the
unconditional probability.
And that's a situation that we
recognize as being one where
we have independence.
So what this result tells
us is that Xn and Xi are
approximately independent.
They become independent in the
limit as n goes to infinity.
So that's what the steady
state theorem tells us.
The initial conditions don't
matter, so your state at some
large time n has nothing to do,
is not affected by what
your initial state was.
Knowing the initial state
doesn't tell you anything
about your state at time
n, therefore the
states at the times--
sorry that should be a 1,
or it should be a 0 --
so the state is not affected by
where the process started.
So if the Markov chain is to
operate for a long time and
we're interested in the question
where is the state,
then your answer would be, I
don't know, it's random.
But it's going to be a
particular j with this
particular probability.
So the steady state
probabilities are interesting
to us and that raises
the question of how
do we compute them.
The way we compute them is by
solving a linear system of
equations, which are called
the balance equations,
together with an extra equation,
the normalization
equation that has to be
satisfied by probability,
because probabilities must
always add up to 1.
We talked about the
interpretation of this
equation last time.
It's basically a conservation
of probability
flow in some sense.
What comes in must get out.
The probability of finding
yourself at state j at a
particular time is the total
probability of the last
transition taking
me into state j.
The last transition takes me
into state j in various ways.
It could be that the previous
time I was at the particular
state, j and i made a transition
from k into j.
So this number here, we
interpret as the frequency
with which transitions
of these particular
type k to j, occur.
And then by adding over all k's
we consider transitions of
all types that lead
us inside state j.
So the probability of being at
the j is the sum total of the
probabilities of
getting into j.
What if we had multiple
recurrent classes?
So if we take this picture
and change it to this.
So here we got a secondary
recurrent class.
If you're here, you
cannot get there.
If you are here, you
What happens in the long run?
Well, in the long run, if you
start from here you're going
to make a transition eventually,
either of this
type and you would end up
here, or you will make a
transitional of that type and
you will end up there.
If you end up here, the long
term statistics of your chain,
that is, the probabilities of
the different states, will be
the steady state probabilities
of this
chain regarded in isolation.
So you go ahead and you solve
this system of equations just
for this chain, and these will
be your steady state
probabilities.
If you happened to
get in here.
If, on the other hand, it
happens that you went there,
given that event, then what
happens in the long run has to
do with just this chain
running by itself.
So you find the steady
state probabilities
inside that sub chain.
So you solve the linear system,
the steady state
equations, for this chain
separately and for that chain
separately.
If you happen to start inside
here then the steady state
probabilities for this sub
chain are going to apply.
Now of course this raises the
question, if I start here, how
do I know whether I'm going
to get here or there?
Well, you don't know,
it's random.
It may turn out that you get to
here, it may turn out that
you get there.
So we will be interested in
calculating the probabilities
that eventually you end up here
versus the probability
that eventually you
end up there.
This is something that we're
going to do towards the end of
today's lecture.
So, as a warm up, just to see
how we interpret those steady
state probabilities, let us look
at our familiar example.
This is a 2-state
Markov chain.
Last time we did write down the
balance equations for this
chain and we found the steady
state probabilities to be 2/7
and 5/7 respectively.
So let us try to calculate
some quantities.
Suppose that you start at
state 1, and you want to
calculate to this particular
probability.
So since we're assuming that
we're starting at state 1,
essentially here we are
conditioning on the initial
state being equal to 1.
Now the conditional probability
of two things
happening is the probability
that the first thing happens.
But we're living in the world
where we said that the initial
state was 1.
And then given that this thing
happened, the probability that
the second thing happens.
But again, we're talking about
conditional probabilities
given that the initial
state was 1.
So what is this quantity?
This one is the transition
probability from state 1 to
state 1, so it's P11.
How about the second
probability?
So given that you started at 1
and the next time you were at
1, what's the probability that
at the time 100 you are at 1?
Now because of the Markov
property, if I tell you that
at this time you are
at 1, it doesn't
matter how you get there.
So this part of the conditioning
doesn't matter.
And what we have is the 99 step
transition probability
from state 1 to state 1.
So the probability that you
get to 1 and then 99 steps
later you find yourself again at
one is the probability that
the first transition takes you
to 1 times the probability
that over the next 99
transitions starting from 1,
after 99 steps you end
up again at state 1.
Now, 99 is possibly a big
number, and so we approximate
this quantity.
We're using the steady state
probability of state 1.
And that gives us an
approximation for this
particular expression.
We can do the same thing
to calculate
something of the same kind.
So you start at state 1.
What's the probability that 100
steps later you are again
at state 1?
So that's going to be P11--
not P --
R11.
The 100 step transition
probability that starting from
1 you get to 1, and then after
you get to 1 at time 100
what's the probability that
the next time you find
yourself at state 2?
This is going to be the
probability P12.
And approximately, since 100
is a large number, this is
approximately pi(1) times P12.
OK.
So that's how we can use steady
state probabilities to
make approximations.
Or you could, for example, if
you continue doing examples of
this kind, you could ask for
what's the probability that X
at time 100 is 1, and also X
at time 200 is equal to 1.
Then this is going to be the
transition probability from 1
to 1 in 100 steps, and then over
the next 100 steps from 1
you get again to 1.
And this is going to be
approximately pi(1) times pi(1).
So we approximate multi-step
transition probabilities by
the steady state probabilities
when the number n that's
involved in here is big.
Now I said that's 99
or 100 is big.
How do we know that it's big
enough so that the limit has
taken effect, and that our
approximation is good?
This has something to do with
the time scale of our Markov
chain, and by time scale, I mean
how long does it take for
the initial states
to be forgotten.
How long does it take for there
to be enough randomness
so that things sort of
mix and it doesn't
matter where you started?
So if you look at this chain, it
takes on the average, let's
say 5 tries to make a transition
of this kind.
It takes on the average 2 tries
for a transition of that
kind to take place.
So every 10 time steps or so
there's a little bit of
randomness.
Over 100 times steps there's
a lot of randomness, so you
expect that the initial state
will have been forgotten.
It doesn't matter.
There's enough mixing and
randomness that happens over
100 time steps.
And so this approximation
is good.
On the other hand, if the
numbers were different, the
story would have
been different.
Suppose that this number is
0.999 and that number is
something like 0.998, so that
this number becomes 0.002, and
that number becomes 0.001.
Suppose that the numbers
were of this kind.
How long does it take to forget
the initial state?
If I start here, there's a
probability of 1 in 1,000 that
next time I'm going
to be there.
So on the average it's going
to take me about a thousand
tries just to leave
that state.
So, over roughly a thousand time
steps my initial state
really does matter.
If I tell you that you started
here, you're pretty certain
that, let's say over the next
100 time steps, you
will still be here.
So the initial state
has a big effect.
In this case we say that this
Markov chain has a much slower
time scale.
It takes a much longer time to
mix, it takes a much longer
time for the initial state to
be forgotten, and this means
that we cannot do this kind of
approximation if the number of
steps is just 99.
Here we might need n to be as
large as, let's say, 10,000 or
so before we can start using
the approximation.
So when one uses that
approximation, one needs to
have some sense of how quickly
does the state move around and
take that into account.
So there's a whole sub-field
that deals with estimating or
figuring out how quickly
different Markov chains mix,
and that's the question of
when can you apply those
steady state approximations.
So now let's get a little closer
to the real world.
We're going to talk about a
famous problem that was posed,
started, and solved by
a Danish engineer
by the name of Erlang.
This is the same person whose
name is given to the Erlang
distribution that we
saw in the context
of the Poisson processes.
So this was more than 100 years
ago, when phones had
just started existing.
And he was trying to figure out
what it would take to set
up a phone system that how many
lines should you set up
for a community to be
able to communicate
to the outside world.
So here's the story.
You've got a village, and that
village has a certain
population, and you want
to set up phone lines.
So you want to set up a number
of phone lines, let's say that
number is B, to the
outside world.
And how do you want
to do that?
Well, you want B to
be kind of small.
You don't want to set
up too many wires
because that's expensive.
On the other hand, you want to
have enough wires so that if a
reasonable number of people
place phone calls
simultaneously, they will all
get a line and they will be
able to talk.
So if B is 10 and 12 people want
to talk at the same time,
then 2 of these people would get
a busy signal, and that's
not something that we like.
We would like B to be large
enough so that there's a
substantial probability, that
there's almost certainty that,
under reasonable conditions,
no one is going
to get a busy signal.
So how do we go about modeling
a situation like this?
Well, to set up a model you
need two pieces, one is to
describe how do phone calls
get initiated, and once a
phone call gets started, how
long does it take until the
phone call is terminated?
So we're going to make the
simplest assumptions possible.
Let's assume that phone
calls originate
as a Poisson process.
That is, out of that population
people do not
really coordinate.
At completely random times,
different people with decide
to pick up the phone.
There's no dependencies between
different people,
there's nothing special about
different times, different
times are independent.
So a Poisson model is a
reasonable way of modeling
this situation.
And it's going to be a Poisson
process with some rate lambda.
Now, the rate lambda would be
easy to estimate in practice.
You observe what happens in
that village just over a
couple of days, and you figure
out what's the rate at which
people attempt to place
phone calls.
Now, about phone calls
themselves, we're going to
make the assumption that the
duration of a phone call is a
random variable that has an
exponential distribution with
a certain parameter mu.
So 1/mu is the mean duration
of a phone call.
So the mean duration, , again,
is easy to estimate.
You just observe what's
happening, see on the average
how long these phone
calls are.
Is the exponential assumption
a good assumption?
Well, it's means that most phone
calls will be kind of
short, but there's going to be a
fraction of phone calls that
are going to be larger, and
then a very small fraction
that are going to
be even larger.
So it sounds plausible.
It's not exactly realistic, that
is, phone calls that last
short of 15 seconds are
not that common.
So either nothing happens
or you have to say a few
sentences and so on.
Also, back into the days when
people used to connect to the
internet using dial up modems,
that assumption was completely
destroyed, because people would
dial up and then keep
their phone line busy for a few
hours, if the phone call
was a free one.
So at those times the
exponential assumption for the
phone call duration was
completely destroyed.
But leaving that detail aside,
it's sort of a reasonable
assumption to just get started
with this problem.
All right, so now that we have
those assumptions, let's try
to come up with the model.
And we're going to set up
a Markov process model.
Now the Poisson process runs in
continuous time, and call
durations being exponential
random variables also are
continuous random variables, so
it seems that we are in a
continuous time universe.
But we have only started
Markov chains for the
discrete time case.
What are we going to do?
We can either develop the theory
of continuous time
Markov chains, which
is possible.
But we are not going to
do that in this class.
Or we can discretize time
and work with a
discrete time model.
So we're going to discretize
time in the familiar way, the
way we did it when we started
the Poisson process.
We're going to take the time
axis and split it into little
discrete mini slots, where
every mini slot
has a duration delta.
So this delta is supposed to
be a very small number.
So what is the state
of the system?
So, you look at the situation
in the system at some
particular time and I ask you
what is going on right now,
what's the information
you would tell me?
Well, you would tell me that
right now out of these capital
B lines, 10 of them are busy,
or 12 of them are busy.
That describes the state of
the system, that tells me
what's happening
at this point.
So we set up our states base by
being the numbers from 0 to
B. 0 corresponds to a state in
which all the phone lines are
free, no one is talking.
Capital B corresponds to
a case where all the
phone lines are busy.
And then you've got
states in between.
And now let's look at the
transition probabilities.
Suppose that right so now we
have i-1 lines that are busy.
Or maybe, let me look here.
Suppose that there's i
lines that are busy.
What can happen the next time?
What can happen is that the new
phone call gets placed, in
which case my state moves up
by 1, or an existing call
terminates, in which case my
state goes down by 1, or none
of the two happens, in which
case I stay at the same state.
Well, it's also possible that
the phone call gets terminated
and a new phone call gets placed
sort of simultaneously.
But when you take your time
slots to be very, very small,
this is going to have a
negligible probability order
of delta squared, so
we ignore this.
So what's the probability of
an upwards transition?
That's the probability that the
Poisson process records an
arrival during a mini slot
of duration delta.
By the definition of the
Poisson process, the
probability of this happening
is just lambda delta.
So each one of these upwards
transitions has the same
probability of lambda delta.
So you've got lambda deltas
everywhere in this diagram.
How about, now, phone
call terminations?
If you had the single call that
was active, so if you
were here, what's the
probability that the phone
call terminates?
So the phone call has an
exponential duration with
parameter mu.
And we discussed before that an
exponential random variable
can be thought of as the
first arrival time
in a Poisson process.
So the probability that you get
this event to happen over
a delta time interval is
just mu times delta.
So if you have a single phone
call that's happening right
now, with probability
mu times delta, that
call is going to terminate.
But suppose that we have
i phone calls that
are currently active.
Each one of them has a
probability of mu delta, of
terminating, but collectively
the probability that one of
them terminates becomes
i times mu delta.
So that's because you get the
mu delta contribution --
the probability of termination
from each one of the different
phone calls.
OK, now this is an approximate
calculation, because it
ignores the possibility that two
phone calls terminate at
the same time.
Again, the way to think of why
this is the correct rate, when
you have i phone calls that are
simultaneously running and
waiting for one of them to
terminate, this is like having
i separate Poisson processes
that are running in parallel,
and you ask for the probability
that one of those
processes records an event.
Now when you put all those
process together, it's like
having a Poisson process with
total rate i times mu, and so
i times mu delta is the overall
probability that
something happens in terms of
phone call terminations at
those times.
So in any case, this is the
transition probability for
downwards transitions.
Now that we've got this, we
can analyze this chain.
This chain has the birth death
form that we discussed towards
the end of last lecture.
And for birth death chains, it's
easy to write it out to
find the steady state
probabilities.
Instead of writing down the
balance equations in the
general form, we think in terms
of a conservation of
probabilities or of transitions
by looking at what
happens across a particular
cut in this diagram.
Number of transitions in the
chain that cross from here to
here has to be approximately
equal to the number of
transitions from here to there
because whatever comes up must
come down and then come
up and so on.
So the frequency with which
transitions of this kind are
observed has to be the same as
the frequency of transitions
of this kind.
What's the frequency of how
often the transitions of this
kind happen?
And by frequency I mean quite
percentage of the mini slots
involve a transition
of this kind?
Well, for a transition of that
kind to happen we need to be
at states i-1, which happens
this much of the time.
And then the probability
lambda delta that the
transition is of this kind.
So the frequency of transitions
of with which this
kind of transition is observed
is lambda delta times pi(i-1).
This is the fraction of time
steps at which a transition
from specifically this
state to specifically
that state are observed.
This has to be the same as
the frequency with which
transitions of that kind are
observed, and that frequency
is going to be i mu delta
times pi(i), and then we
cancel the deltas, and we are
left with this equation here.
So this equation expresses pi(i)
in terms of pi(i-1).
So if we knew pi(0) we
can use that equation
to determine pi(1).
Once we know pi(1), we can use
that equation to determine
pi(2), and so on,
you keep going.
And the general formula that
comes out of this, I will not
do the algebra, it's a
straightforward substitution,
you find that pi(i), the steady
state probability of
state i is given by this
expression, which involves the
pi(0) from which we started.
Now what is pi(0)?
Well, we don't know yet, but
we can find it by using the
normalization equation.
The sum of pi(i) has
to be equal to 1.
So the sum of all of those
numbers has to be equal to 1.
And the only way that this can
happen is by setting pi(0) to
be equal to that particular
number.
So if I tell you the value of
capital B, you can set up this
Markov chain, you can calculate
pi(0), and then you
can calculate pi(i), and so you
know what fraction, you
know the steady state
probabilities of this chain,
so you can answer
the question.
If I drop in at a random time,
how likely is it that I'm
going to find the states
to be here, or the
states to be there?
So the steady state
probabilities are
probabilities, but we also
interpret them as frequencies.
So once I find pi(i), it also
tells me what fraction of the
time is the state equal to i.
And you can answer that question
for every possible i.
Now, why did we do
this exercise?
We're interested in
the probability of
the system is busy.
So if a person, a new phone
call gets placed, it just
drops out of the sky.
According to that Poisson
process, that new phone call
is going to find the system
at a random state.
That random state is described
in steady state by the
probabilities pi(i)'s.
And the probability that you
find the system to be busy is
the probability that when you
drop in the state happens to
be that particular number B. So
i sub b is the probability
of being busy.
And this is the probability
that you would like to be
small in a well engineered
system.
So you ask the question, how
should, given my lambda and
mu, my design question is to
determine capital B the number
of phone lines so that
this number is small.
Could we have done, could we
figure out a good value for B
by doing a back of the
envelope calculation?
Let's suppose that lambda is
30 and that mu is 1/3.
So I guess that's, let
us these rates to
be calls per minute.
And this mu, again, is
a rate per minute.
Again, the units of mu are going
to be calls per minute.
So since our time unit is
minutes, the mean duration of
calls is 1/mu minutes.
So a typical call, or
on the average a
call lasts for 3 minutes.
So you get 30 calls
per minute.
Each call lasts for 3 minutes
on the average.
So on the average, if
B was infinite,
every call goes through.
How many calls would be
active on the average?
So you get 30 per minute.
If a call lasted exactly 1
minute, then at any time you
would have 30 calls
being active.
Now a call lasts on the
average for 3 minutes.
So during each minute
you generate 90
minutes of talking time.
So by thinking in terms of
averages you would expect that
at any time there would
be about 90
calls that are active.
And if 90 calls are active on
the average, you could say OK,
I'm going to set up my
capital B to be 90.
But that's not very good,
because if the average number
of phone calls that want to
happen is if the average
number is 90, sometimes you're
going to have 85, sometimes
you will have 95.
And to be sure that the phone
calls will go through you
probably want to choose your
capital B to be a number a
little larger than 90.
How much larger than 90?
Well, this is a question that
you can answer numerically.
So you go through the
following procedure.
I tried different values of
capital B. For any given value
of capital B, I do this
numerical calculation, I find
the probability that the system
is busy, and then I ask
what's the value of B that makes
my probability of being
busy to be, let's say,
roughly 1 %.
And if you do that calculation
with the parameters that they
gave you, you find that B would
be something like 106.
So with the parameters they gave
where you have, on the
average, 90 phone calls being
active, you actually need some
margin to protect against the
[?] fluctuation, if suddenly
by chance more people want to
talk, and if you want to have
a good guarantee that an
incoming person will have a
very small probability of
finding a busy system, then
you will need about
106 phone lines.
So that's the calculation and
the argument that the Erlang
went through a long time ago.
It's actually interesting that
Erlang did this calculation
before Markov chains
were invented.
So Markov's work, and the
beginning of work on Markov
chains, happens about 10-15
years after Erlang.
So obviously he didn't call
that a Markov chain.
But it was something that he
could study from first
principles.
So this is a pretty
useful thing.
These probabilities that come
out of that model, at least in
the old days, they would all
be very well tabulated in
handbooks that every decent
phone company engineer would
sort of have with them.
So this is about as practical
as it gets.
It's one of the sort of
standard real world
applications of Markov chains.
So now to close our subjects,
we're going to consider a
couple of new skills and see how
we can calculate the few
additional interesting
quantities that have to do
with the Markov chain.
So the problem we're going to
deal with here is the one I
hinted that when I was talking
about this picture.
You start at a transient
state, you're going to
eventually end up
here or there.
We want to find the
probabilities of one option of
the two happening or the
other happening.
So in this picture we
have a class of
states that's are transient.
These are transient because
you're going to move around
those states, but there's a
transition that you can make,
and you go to a state from
which you cannot escape
afterwards.
Are you going to end
up here or are you
going to end up there?
You don't know.
It's random.
Let's try to calculate the
probability that you
end up at state 4.
Now, the probability that you
end up at state 4 will depend
on where you start.
Because if you start here, you
probably have more chances of
getting to 4 because you get
that chance immediately,
whereas if you start here
there's more chances that
you're going to escape that way
because it kind of takes
you time to get there.
It's more likely that
you exit right away.
So the probability of exiting
and ending up at state 4 will
depend on the initial state.
That's why when we talk about
these absorption probability
we include an index i that
tells us what the
initial state is.
And we want to find this
absorption probability, the
probability that we end
up here for the
different initial states.
Now for some initial states this
is very easy to answer.
If you start at state 4, what's
the probability that
eventually you end up in
this part of the chain?
It's 1.
You're certain to be there,
that's where you started.
If you start at state 5, what's
the probability that
you end up eventually
at state 4?
It's probability 0, there's
no way to get there.
Now, how about if you start
at a state like state 2?
If you start at state 2 then
there's a few different things
that can happen.
Either you end up at state 4
right away and this happens
with probability 0.2, or you
end up at state 1, and this
happens with probability 0.6.
So if you end up at state
4, you are done.
We are there.
If you end up at state
1, then what?
Starting from state 1 there's
two possibilities.
Either eventually you're going
to end up at state 4, or
eventually you're going
to end up at state 5.
What's the probability
of this happening?
We don't know what it is, but
it's what we defined to be a1.
This is the probability --
a1 is the probability --
that eventually you settle in
state 4 given that the initial
state was 1.
So this probability is a1.
So our event of interest
can happen in two ways.
Either I go there directly,
or I go here
with probability 0.6.
And given that I go there,
eventually I end up at state
4, which happens with
probability a1.
So the total probability of
ending up at state 4 is going
to be the sum of the
probabilities of the different
ways that this event
can happen.
So our equation, in this case,
is going to be, that's a2, is
going to be 0.2 (that's the
probability of going there
directly) plus with probability
0.8 I end up at
state 1, and then from state 1
I will end up at state 4 with
probability a1.
So this is one particular
equation that we've got for
what happens if we start
from this state.
We can do a similar argument
starting from any other state.
Starting from state i the
probability that eventually I
end up at state 4 is, we
consider the different
possible scenarios of where do
I go next, which is my state
j, with probability Pij.
Next time I go to j, and given
that I started at j, this is
the probability that I
end up at state 4.
So this equation that we have
here is just an abstract
version in symbols of what we
wrote down for the particular
case where the initial
state was 2.
So you write down an equation
of this type for every state
inside here.
You'll have a separate equation
for a1, a2, and a3.
And that's going to be a system
of 3 equations with 3
unknowns, the a's inside
the transient states.
So you can solve that 3 by
3 system of equations.
Fortunately, it turns out to
have a unique solution, and so
once you solve it you have found
the probabilities of
absorption and the probability
that eventually you get
absorbed at state 4.
Now, in the picture that we had
here, this was a single
state, and that one was
a single state.
How do things change if our
recurrent, or trapping sets
consist of multiple states?
Well, it doesn't really matter
that we have multiple states.
All that matters is that this
is one lump and once we get
there we are stuck in there.
So if the picture was, let's
say, like this, 0.1 and 0.2,
that basically means that
whenever you are in that state
there's a total probability of
0.3 of ending in that lump and
getting stuck inside
that lump.
So you would take that picture
and change it and make it
instead a total probability of
0.3, of ending somewhere
inside that lump.
And similarly, you take this
lump and you view it as just
one entity, and from any state
you record the total
probability that given
that I'm here I
end up in that entity.
So basically, if the only
thing you care is the
probability that you're going
to end up in this lump, you
can replace that lump with a
single state, view it as a
single state, and calculate
probabilities using this formula.
All right, so now we know
where the chain is
going to get to.
At least we know
probabilistically.
We know with what probability
it is going to go here, and
that also tells us the
probability that eventually
it's going to get there.
Other question, how long is it
going to take until we get to
either this state
or that state?
We can call that event
absorption, meaning that the
state got somewhere into a
recurrent class from which it
could not get out.
Okay.
Let's deal with that question
for the case where we have
only 1 absorbing state.
So here our Markov chain is a
little simpler than the one in
the previous slide.
We've got our transient
states, we've got our
recurrent state, and once you
get into the recurrent state
you just stay there.
So here we're certain that no
matter where we start we're
going to end up here.
How long is it going to take?
Well, we don't know.
It's a random variable.
The expected value of that
random variable,
let's call it mu.
But how long it takes to get
there certainly depends on
where we start.
So let's put in our notation
again this index i that
indicates where we
started from.
And now the argument is going to
be of the same type as the
one we used before.
We can think in terms of a tree
once more, that considers
all the possible options.
So suppose that you
start at state 1.
Starting from state 1, the
expected time until you end up
dropping states is mu1.
Now, starting from state 1, what
are the possibilities?
You make your first transition,
and that first
transition is going to take
you either to state
2 or to state 3.
It takes you to state 2 with
probability 0.6, it takes you
to state 3 with probability
0.4.
Starting from state 2,
eventually you're going to get
to state 4.
How long does it take?
We don't know, it's
a random variable.
But the expected time until
this happens is mu2.
Starting from state 2, how long
does it take you to get
to state 4.
And similarly starting from
state 3, it's going to take
you on the average mu3
time steps until you
get to state 4.
So what's the expected value
of the time until I
end at state 4?
So with probability 0.6, I'm
going to end up at state 2 and
from there on it's going to be
expected time mu2, and with
probability 0.4 I'm going to
end up at state 3, and from
there it's going to take
me so much time.
So this is the expected time
it's going to take me after
the first transition.
But we also spent 1 time step
for the first transition.
The total time to get there
is the time of the first
transition, which is 1, plus
the expected time starting
from the next state.
This expression here is the
expected time starting from
the next state, but we also need
to account for the first
transition, so we add 1.
And this is going
to be our mu1.
So once more we have a linear
equation that ties together
the different mu's.
And the equation starting from
state 4 in this case, of
course is going to be simple,
starting from that state the
expected number of steps it
takes you to get there for the
first time is of course, 0
because you're already there.
So for that state this is fine,
and for all the other
states you get an equation
of this form.
Now we're going to have an
equation for every state.
It's a system of linear
equations, once more we can
solve them, and this gives us
the expected times until our
chain gets absorbed in
this absorbing state.
And it's nice to know that
this system of equations
always has a unique solution.
OK so this was the expected
time to absorption.
For this case where we had this
scene absorbing state.
Suppose that we have our
transient states and that we
have multiple recurrent
classes, or
multiple absorbing states.
Suppose you've got the
picture like this.
And we want to calculate the
expected time until we get
here or there.
Expected time until we get
to an absorbing state.
What's the trick?
Well, we can lump both of these
states together and
think of them as just one bad
state, one place for which
we're interested in how long
it takes us to get there.
So lump them as one state, and
accordingly kind of merge all
of those probabilities.
So starting from here, my
probability that the next I
end up in this lump and they
get absorbed is going to be
this probability plus
that probability.
So we would change
that picture.
Think of this as being
just one big state.
And sort of add those two
probabilities together to come
up with a single probability,
which is the probability that
starting from here next
time I find myself at
some absorbing state.
So once you know how to deal
with a situation like this,
you can also find expected times
to absorption for the
case where you've got multiple
absorbing states.
You just lump all of those
multiple absorbing states into
a single one.
Finally, there's a
kind of related
quantity that's of interest.
The question is almost the same
as in the previous slide,
except that here we do not have
any absorbing states.
Rather, we have a single
recurrent class of states.
You start at some state i.
You have a special state,
that is state s.
And you ask the question, how
long is it going to take me
until I get to s for
the first time?
It's a single recurrent
class of states.
So you know that the state keeps
circulating here and it
keeps visiting all of
the possible states.
So eventually this state
will be visited.
How long does it take
for this to happen?
Ok.
So we're interested in how
long it takes for this to
happen, how long it takes until
we get to s for the
first time.
And we don't care about what
happens afterwards.
So we might as well change this
picture and remove the
transitions out of s and to make
them self transitions.
Is the answer going to change?
No.
The only thing that we changed
was what happens
after you get to s.
But what happens after you
get to s doesn't matter.
The question we're dealing with
is how long does it take
us to get to s.
So essentially, it's after we
do this transformation --
it's the same question as
before, what's the time it
takes until eventually
we hit this state.
And it's now in this new
picture, this state is an
absorbing state.
Or you can just think from
first principles.
Starting from the state itself,
s, it takes you 0 time
steps until you get to s.
Starting from anywhere else,
you need one transition and
then after the first transition
you find yourself
at state j with probability Pij
and from then on you are
going to take expected time
Tj until you get to that
terminal state s.
So once more these equations
have a unique solution, you
can solve them and
find the answer.
And finally, there's a related
question, which is the mean
recurrence time of s.
In that question you start
at s, the chain will move
randomly, and you ask how long
is it going to take until I
come back to s for
the next time.
So notice the difference.
Here we're talking the first
time after time 0, whereas
here it's just the first
time anywhere.
So here if you start from
s, Ts* is not 0.
You want to do at least one
transition and that's how long
it's going to take me until
it gets back to s.
Well, how long does it take
me until I get back to s?
I do my first transition, and
then after my first transition
I calculate the expected time
from the next state how long
it's going to take me until
I come back to s.
So all of these equations that I
wrote down, they all kind of
look the same.
But they are different.
So you can either memorize all
of these equations, or instead
what's better is to just
to get the basic idea.
That is, to calculate
probabilities or expected
values you use the total
probability or total
expectation theorem and
conditional the first
transition and take
it from there.
So you're going to get a little
bit of practice with
these skills in recitation
tomorrow, and of course it's
in your problem set as well.